evidentemente
en en la cúpula rusa la Guerra de
Ucrania ha generado una serie disputas a
lo interno de los más allegados a a
Putin en este caso prigo sin y el
ministro de la defensa
se ha hecho evidente que las relaciones
no son las mejores y las declaraciones
que él ha dado hoy demuestran que hay
espacios cuales ya Aparecen insalvables
las disputas y las luchas que se dan
habitualmente en estos escenarios
tan complejos en países como Rusia donde
siempre tenemos una una élite que de una
manera u otra es la que incide en las
decisiones que puedan tomarse
en ambientes de de conflictos que no es
un país democrático donde vamos a tener
interacción de distintos grupos que de
una manera u otra puedan disminuir lo
que es natural en los escenarios de
poder que es el el narcisismo y la
vanidad que de una manera u otra en ese
a los que están
dominando digamos así la situación en
ese país se hablaba usted de las
declaraciones de pregosí hoy en ellas ha
desmontado también el relato de Moscú
sobre la guerra y ha dicho que la
invasión fue casi una idea de eso quería
preguntarle cuál es la relación de prigo
sin computing porque parece que lo deja
a un lado de sus críticas
la relación de pregon es una relación no
viene del ámbito digamos militar sino de
alguien que estuvo cerca Putin gracias a
sus habilidades culinarias Y por
supuesto
un clásico de la política nos muestra
que quienes
medran o
progresan dentro de los ambientes de
poder son aquellos que son más asiduos a
las personas que están en el poder y que
de una manera u otra le dicen al
gobernante lo que desea en Escuchar Pues
eso eso es algo eso es un clásico de
azorín es decir no es una persona que
viene del ámbito militar sino un
allegado a Putin que no tiene nada que
ver con el entorno militar es contrario
a un militar de formación como es el
caso de
Sí parece que brigosin se ha quedado
solo en su llamado a ese alzamiento
contra la cúpula militar que puede pasar
con Wagner si pierde el apoyo del
kremlin bueno es una creación de es una
forma de entender
esos mercenarios que pueden estar
presentes no solamente en Ucrania sino
que los vemos presentes también en Rusia
y sin el apoyo del kremlin evidentemente
no van a sobrevivir
Claro pues le agradezco que haya estado
con nosotros esta noche
Muchas gracias